moi je vais très très très radicale les
écoles souhaite comme la torche du
soldat inconnu elle ne doit jamais
s'éteindre c'est à dire qu'une école
doit tout le temps restait ouverte et on
doit se débrouiller s'organiser pour que
ce fondamental là ne se ne s'éteignent
pas même 30 secondes la permanence doit
être totale les écoles on fait tout pour
100 gagne et on organise tout autour de
l'école parce que pour moi je suis très
radicale le but n'est pas forcément
exclusivement d'avoir les lunettes du
coronavirus et de sauver tous les
adultes possible il est de souvenez de
ce 2 go et là le gouvernement sonore de
comprendre que l'avenir du pays repose
exclusivement sur l'éducation et des
enfants donc il faut peut-être tout
sacrifier sauf l'école c'est la chose la
plus importante qui fait république qui
fait nation qui sait à venir
malheureusement il ya des gens vieux qui
meurt il des gens moins vieux ça c'est
un truc non c'est pas ça c'est pas vrai
qu'on prend une bordée de truites à
chaque fois mais c'est comme si comme
vous m'interrompez non mais qu'est ce
que je vais dire n'est pas ce que je
vais dire on parla du personnel
enseignant etc
mais on ne parle jamais des enfants on
parle de l'école du personnel éducatif
mais il ya il ya un personnage une
personne qu'on oublie dans 100% des cas
c'est l'enfant mais je vais m'en parler
oui mais je vais vous les landes c'est
l'avenir et je trouve que mène et médium
la crau ensuite grave erreur en
attendant les librairies wyss et humilie
lui même en interne dans les librairies
ce terrain est libre et c'est symbolique
mais là on en est pas dans une centrale
je trouve que et dieu sait si j'ai cogné
sur le gouvernant mâcon depuis très
longtemps pour d'autres raisons là je
trouve que emmanuel macron sonore et que
si une grande décision qui est vraiment
digne de la france je n'ai pas entendu
ni rancoeur ni bruno donc rokhaya bruno
et ensuite on refait un tour de temps
alors moi je pense qu enfin j'ai dit non
mais je suis tout à fait sensible à ce
qui se dit jusqu'ici j'ai apprécié le
fait que ce qui était mentionné le
travail qu'avait fait le personnel de
l'éducation nationale qui vraiment à
coeur le fait que les enfants aient
accès à une scolarité
je pense que c'est vraiment important de
souligner que depuis un an et a vraiment
une série d'efforts continus qui
permettent aux enfants de continuer leur
scolarité
le fait est que ils sont exposés à une
situation extrêmement difficile
énormément d'absence dans l'est dans
l'est dans l'établissement scolaire moi
g
une amie qui enseigne en seine saint
denis qui m'a expliqué que déjà il n'y
avait pas de médecin scolaire ce qui est
le cas dans plein dedans plein
d'établissement puis 13
c'est un problème enfin structurelles
qui précède à la situation sanitaire
dans son établissement donc l'infirmière
était malade
leleu il n'y avait pas de cpt parce
qu'ils étaient absents l'adjoint
gestionnaire également donc avec une
principale et des surveillants pour
prendre en charge non seulement les
élèves mais aussi rennes faire respecter
le protocole sanitaire
c'est impossible c'est à dire qu'il ya
aussi quelque chose qu'il faut mesurer
c'est un phénomène d'épuisement
en fait des personnes qui sont en charge
de l'éducation nationale et ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose dont il faut dont
il faut tenir compte et pour moi dont on
parle pas suffisamment parle d'école
l'école c'est pas pareil quand on est
tout petit que quand on est au lycée
donc pour les lycéens effectivement on
est bon on a mis en place l'organisation
de groupes
je sais des enseignants de collèges ont
demandé la même chose ça n'a pas été
accordé et c'est plus difficile
d'assurer un enseignement à distance
pour un petit qui entrent en 6e que pour
un adolescent qui a 17 ans 18 ans qui
est capable en fait d'avoir une forme
d'autonomie
donc ça aussi c'est ça veut dire que le
point des dispositions qui tiennent
compte de l'âge des élèves et ça je
pense que c'est aussi quelque chose
venir compter pour ça que je dis non
parce que je pense qu'il vaut prendre
des mesures qui correspondent à la fois
restauration scolaire des enfants
quelle est leur situation aussi
personnel